[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hello, my name is Reto Meier.
And welcome to "This Week in
Android Development" on
Monday, September 9, 2013.
Last week, Ankur and Nick put
their unique Anglo-Australian
spin on "This Week in Android
Development," while I was
putting a unique spin on my
toasted marshmallows.
My absence didn't slow down
the team though with the
release of new "DevBytes" for
animating map markers,
effective efficient prefetching,
understanding the
Patchfield audio architecture,
and implementing card flip
animations.
The Google Play Games services
team were also hard at work
with another episode of "Game
On!," covering how to best
support game controllers
for your Android games.
This week, "Android Design in
Action" will be walking you
through some of the most common
UX issues we encounter,
and I'll be presenting the next
episode of my efficient
data transfers "DevBytes,"
uncovering how to batch and
bundle your transfers
using sync adapters.
Not to be outdone, Daniel is
back with another "DevByte"
describing how to perform
ListView cell insertion
animations.
New in documentation last week
was this guide to getting
started with the Android
testing framework.
And if you're in the UK, the
latest update of BBC's iPlayer
let's you download your favorite
TV shows to enjoy
when you're on the tube.
That's all for "This Week in
Android Development." Be sure
to check out this week's
"DevBytes." I'm Reto Meier,
and I saw two shooting
starts last night.
I wished on them, but they
were only satellites.